so we hear this term a lot develop a
character what does that mean and how to
kind of screenwriter work on their
characters they do it by really
understanding what the characters
bleeding from it's always about that
manure in Breaking Bad
that is Walters nemesis he's his
brother-in-law Hank he's this blowhard
he's an alpha male and and he is Walters
opposite he's his scourge and the way we
develop characters in a story is they
all have to either be ripping at the
wound of the hero or healing him which
is it for each character and you got to
decide which side the the characters on
and then you have to ask yourself why is
he a blowhard in in terms of this guy's
character in terms of Hank why is he so
interested in being a big deal well his
wound is that he doesn't matter that
he's not a parent
he's actually jealous of Walt's fact
that the Walt has a family and so in his
desire to dominate Walt all of that is
part of it but you know there's a huge
element of simple arbitrary surprise
involved in this Vince Gilligan says he
didn't know who he was going to have in
his story when he did the pilot he was
going to kill off Jesse he wasn't gonna
have Hank when you see the story and you
you understand how great a character is
in commercial television especially you
can change it you can say oh well he's
this is a guy who I really want to
explore this is a character I really
wanna develop because of the
relationship he had with wall
works so well often and this is why I
die it's not like a broker but
television is such a cool medium is that
you can
change a lot of stuff in TV you can't
really do it in the movies you can do to
some extent but in television the pilot
gets done you look at it you go oh my
God look at that look at this this is a
storyline these two characters mesh in a
way that I think we need to explore
movies can only do that maybe once you
get it you go okay geez we can reshoot
maybe if we have enough money we can
reshoot once but television gives you
that capability to do week after week
even year after year you can bring in
new characters so the development
process in television is really almost
hey I can put it up and see how it works
you know in movies people always think
they go to a movie if you live out in
Iowa you go to the movie and you watch a
movie and it's bad and you say to
yourself
Hollywood's so stupid it's full of so
many stupid people look at how crappy
this movie is I knew in two minutes this
was a crappy movie they must be complete
idiots out there to put this stuff I'm
gonna go out there and make a bundle cuz
look at this well here's of course the
truth when they made the movie when they
shot the movie when the movie was
already on the cards and they saw it
they knew they had a crappy movie too
but it was too late to change you'd
already shot it the budgets weren't
going to allow you to reshoot it or
change it right so it's very easy when
you see a finished product to go oh
that's crap what only an idiot would
have made that but in television you get
the chance to see what you've done and
go oh I can change it we're gonna shoot
a whole new story next week and oh
Jessie I love him let's put him in the
show Oh Hank he's a great character
let's have him in there too Gilligan
will tell you he didn't know 90% of
where Walt was gonna go when he first
wrote this pilot it is only by seeing it
and then going oh yeah that's what we
have that he could develop all these
characters and that's part of what makes
TV such a great medium - you get
do-overs you get do-overs a lot of the
and movies don't do that although I
think movies should do that and we get
called in a story doctors now sometimes
because it's so much cheaper to shoot a
movie than it used to be that they're
beginning to do the same thing it's like
well we got all this in the can but we
could shoot again we don't have any big
stars we could bring everybody back the
production costs aren't that high that
movies are becoming a little bit more
like the TV development process because
of that because characters can change
and we can do a reshoot not for 10
million dollars now but for maybe half a
million so let's change the movie up so
the two mediums are interestingly
becoming more similar because of
Technology in a way so that's a
development question that really is
driven by technology I because I think I
already answered how you develop a
character in terms of his core wound
that's really always the place to start
but when you can see an actor inhabit
the character you really and a
particular actor can change a character
immensely there's a movie called heat
Michael Mann and heat is a movie and the
two protagonists are Robert De Niro and
Al Pacino now someone made heat before
heat it was I think an english movie
maybe it wrong was but with two actors
and they and then in this scene it was
the exact same scene that was shot all
the same words all the same dialogue
between but instead of Pacino and De
Niro it was these two other actors now
if you go and look at those two scenes
both saying dialogue I think even
similar camera angles the one between
the two actors I won't name it's flat as
a board you're just like okay the one
between Pacino and De Niro is electric
it's amazing so never underestimate how
you're gonna the energy that actors
rain - a scene is immense and I think
story snobs and I can be one sometimes I
think well it doesn't matter you know
you use the author you create the whole
story if the story's in there it doesn't
matter that's not true so you develop a
story based sometimes on specific actors
and specific actors can change your
entire conception of your story once you
see them do the scene that heat is a
great example of how actors develop and
bring an enormous energy to - two roles
that two other actors would absolutely
not be able to do and there's a shot by
shot remake by the way of of a famous
Hitchcock movie psycho and the guy who
remade it did it shot-for-shot line by
line and it's very uncompelled very
uncompelled and part of it is because
the actors and also there's tiny little
differences in timing like ticking
clocks and good-news bad-news tiny
little differences Carrie is another
example De Palma did it and then
somebody else did it and when you look
at the two side-by-side you'll see that
the actors are different and there's
tiny little differences in ticking clock
timings and sequences but one falls
completely flat do you think that the
timing has been sped up in recent films
or is that just my own it's interesting
in the Carey example the the timing is
actually there's the ticking clock time
is actually lessened but that actually
makes it boring more boring because he
doesn't draw out the tension he doesn't
really and he's a great director and a
great creator but I'm just saying in
terms of developing a story and
developing the characters tiny little
differences in timing and and again
who's playing the part make a huge huge
difference I'm thinking if one Carrie
would go back home yeah and she would
walk in the house and there's this cloud
that was
/ yes and at first she wouldn't know
what to expect and so you would be in
that moment of suspense waiting to see
how his mother going to react yes and
mother I think played by Piper Lori's
she's amazing right and that's an
actress who's sort of bringing that
electricity to that role so as a writer
we really want to leave that space in
the development process for a particular
actor to come in and see it and and and
you know obviously this is true but when
you write with I always say hey if
you've got a particular actor in mind
write with that actor in mind if it
energizes you because actors can
mesmerize and completely change the
development of a character their energy
what they bring to it thinking of like a
Melissa Leo or a Robin right yeah they
can really just come in and and just
with their uncomfortable silences or
looks or just body you know just
something and just really change it and
make it from flat to three-dimensional
power of star is immense it's misused in
Hollywood because people say hey you
know I'll get so-and-so for the movie if
the currency of development is I've got
Matthew McConaughey therefore you're
gonna make a hundred million dollars you
don't even need to know the script right
that's what sometimes I tell the money
guys well there's some truth to that but
Matthew McConaughey can also be really
bad in a horrible story but if the
reason stars are still the currency in
Hollywood although less than they used
to be is they really can bring an
electricity to a part that you're simply
not going to be able to have without
them so I always say right with Matthew
McConaughey in mind or right with Woody
Harrelson in mind and and that'll
probably help you and inspire you in
your story even if you don't wind up
getting them they do bring an enormous
power to a story it's it's false for a
writer to say you know I don't care who
plays the part this is about the story
not the not the star property
managers and agents are idiots so the
fact that they're always talking in
terms of stars is because stars really
do matter they can completely transform
a project I think the energy between
Harrelson and Makani Makani in intruder
detected was a big piece of why that
show worked so well
you